[Music]
that's a whole lot of red
jake gyllenhaal has sent taylor swift's
fans into a frenzy
with his new red themed photo shoot for
w magazine
yeah it was a it was a great photo shoot
reportedly jake and taylor dated for
three months in 2010
and it's speculated that he's the
subject of much of taylor's 2012 album
red
which had its resurgence in 2021 when
she re-recorded it
[Music]
in the video for one of her hit songs
off the album 22
taylor is seen rocking red heart
sunglasses
similar to the ones jake is seen wearing
in his photo shoot did you see it
although jake doesn't mention taylor in
his interview for the magazine
fans couldn't help but point out more
similarities between the actors spread
and his pop star x here are some of the
best reactions one fan tweeted a shot
from the photo shoot and captioned it
quote jake gyllenhaal vacuuming taylor
swift's scarf
another fan tweeted quote jake
gyllenhaal is really in his red era huh
what's going on here and i think this
tweet from a fan sums it up next to a
collage of jake's photo shoot they wrote
quote everyone stay calm stay calm
these are things that make me break out
in a full body sweat this past november
taylor celebrated the re-release of her
red album
red is the second album swift has
re-recorded following the release of
fearless taylor's version in april
the night of red's re-release the 31
year old appeared on the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon
and opened up about her excitement over
the never before heard tracks that
didn't make it onto her original release
of red and were featured on red taylor's
version
in the process i've dug up these songs
that i wrote along the way that didn't
make the album because i i thought
i want to save this for the next album
um but then i the next album would just
be a completely different thing so i'd
be like well what's going to happen to
that
um and and it turns out this it's an
opportunity for me to go back and
re-record
all the music that was on the original
album and then what i'm really excited
about is these songs that no one's ever
heard before that that were supposed to
be on that album
you